[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
one million dollars
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy [__] around you
find out right I mean that's how it
works you [__] around you find out and
there's no better two people [__]
around and finding out
then Donald Trump and his attorneys uh
news
breaking uh last night we found out that
uh judge Middlebrook in Florida
was going to honor the sanctions that
Hillary Clinton's lawyers asked for
after Donald Trump tried to and the 30
other uh defendants he was suing Hillary
Clinton was the main person but there
was anything like up to 30 other [__]
people on this lawsuit that he was
trying to sue
now of course over nothing
lies of course
anyways
uh it get thrown out and they asked for
sanctions because it was stupid and
there was no basis for the lawsuit it
was frivolous and I'm so that judge
granted almost up to a million bucks is
like 900 and some odd thousand a million
bucks let's just call it a million bucks
uh to those defendants against and that
Donald Trump was trying to sue in
Florida now he filed these lawsuits in
Florida
um obviously because he wants to pick a
certain judge who gives him special
treatment I don't know what the [__] she
was paid to get that special treatment
but when you file a lawsuit in federal
court it's kind of like a like a lottery
right you don't get to choose your judge
and you kind of get to choose your
District
that you're in but there's a lot of
Judges within that District
and he picked the wrong [__] one now
this morning
and we find out that a Haba his attorney
and Donald Trump have dropped their
lawsuit
against
James in New York and the reason why is
because they
they probably can't afford the [__]
first million dollars in sanctions let
alone the next [__] million dollars
in sanctions because you know you know
tis James is not gonna [__] around she's
gonna make him find out
for sure
hell boy oh boy
oh boy
well
Miss Haba ended up on the bonehead of
the week
for this now my guess is that if this
poll was done this afternoon she might
win
but um we'll see if she won in the
second hour of the show you know we do
the bonehead of the week because it is
Friday and every single Friday we go
through the bonehead of the week where
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week but I think we're gonna have
a special treat
um during bonehead the week we've never
done this before
we're gonna have a guest on to tell us
what they know about this Haba story
this frivolous lawsuit story
and so special guest arriving during
bonehead of the week I don't think we've
ever had a guest during bone of the week
not that I can remember we do a lot of
them it's every week it's it's Fridays
in the second hour I don't know if
you're new to the show here which we got
a lot of new audience members every
single Friday we do a poll it's out on
Twitter you need to follow us there at
Tony Michaels pod
you can vote for bonehead of the week
every single week but you must come over
to the YouTube channel And subscribe
because you can vote there too on the
community tab every single week for
bonehead of the week
but here's what happens you vote for
bone end of the week
and then we break it down for you in the
second hour of the show of who wins
we're practicing democracy here folks
that's what we're doing we're practicing
and these people wouldn't normally get
your vote anyway so why not make it a
little fun right that's how we see it
but I don't think we've ever had a guest
on Boone of the week I don't think so
maybe I'm wrong it could be I'll ask
Gabe Sanchez when he gets here
when you get him on camera maybe we have
maybe we haven't I don't really remember
if we have or not and there's going to
be a lot of good appearances in bonehead
of the week I'm sure now Mr Ron DeSantis
that [__] racist piece of [__] the
governor of Florida
ah he's gonna you know he's that really
he doesn't like African-American studies
that much you know you might learn some
things
that you don't want to know that you
might you you racists don't want to
teach their [__] children about bad
things that racism and bigotry can do to
marginalize groups of people
they don't want to teach them that [__]
they don't want to teach them the bad
things we've done they don't want to
teach them the stains on our country
they want it to be all right I mean all
white all right oh oh I don't know
Nazism that maybe that's what it's
called they're gonna listen they're
banning books
they're banning books
they're banning African-American studies
they Banning what you want to learn and
what you don't want to learn
the truth is what they're banning
they're banning the truth and the reason
why is because the truth does not serve
them
thank you
democracy does not serve them that's why
they love authoritarianism and fascism
that's why they love it
Ron DeSantis
so we'll probably tick through that
story
as well
and also and for the bonehead of the
week this week we have the George Santos
Saga
oh if you've been watching for any
length of time here you know my feelings
on George Zantos
and what I feel about George Santos he's
not again he's just a republican that's
it that's all he is he's just a [__]
Republican this guy is not special in
any shape form his lies are not special
they're all Republican Lies by the way
every [__] last one of them is a
republican right every single one he's
told every fraud every grift he's done
is all been done in the past by
Republicans all of it
he just likes all the lies and all the
griffs and all the fraud he likes it all
and he's a dumb [__] so he [__] him up
in fact he [__] it up bad I I am
guessing by the end of the spring we
will have Santos trading cards I I would
say there's probably going to be Santos
nft trading cards don't you think I
would imagine we're gonna have that I
mean I wouldn't put it past him
I think that's gonna be a thing
he might as well get on that one too
he might as well why not
I mean he's stealing money from veterans
and and dead dogs why wouldn't he want
to steal money from these these these
manga supporters out there
foreign
ties that are going to be worth
gazillions of dollars
they're going to be so rare and so not
stolen aren't yeah okay
I would imagine he'll get in on that
he'll need a legal defense fund oh yeah
he's gonna have his own he's gonna
definitely have a legal defense fund
you're gonna see that 100 we're gonna be
talking about on this show the George
Santos has started to grip for legal
funds
he's gonna grift Maga for legal funds
and they're gonna pay him they're gonna
give him the [__] money
I mean he may or may not use it for
lawyers he's gonna need it
I wonder I wonder this morning we need
to ask Gabe Sanchez is don't forget to
let me ask Gabe Sanchez when he gets on
the show
if if he could check his email box if
the Trump Camp is already sending out
emails to collect money for the
sanctions
other privileged lawsuit that they filed
to convince the same people that are
going to give him money
that he was he ended the 2016 election
stolen from him that's literally what
that lawsuit was about
literally the lawsuit was about that he
tried they tried to steal the 2016
election from him
the projection never ends the judge seen
right through it and said yeah I'm gonna
give him the sanctions
you [__] boneheads I would be uh
really surprised if Elena Haba has a law
license
um in the near future
she seems like a [__] bonehead
and all these lawyers around Trump
almost every single one of them just
lose a lot of license lose their law
license lose their law license I don't I
don't think it's I don't think it's an
easy thing to get a law license in Most
states right like it's a difficult thing
yeah yeah most time you gotta go get
your law degree and then you gotta go
take the bar
it can't be [__] easy the test even
people who go to law school and do a
good job I'm sure it's still [__]
difficult to [__]
and you're just gonna throw that all
away for this fat [__] slob really
you kidding me
I don't know what he's got on these
people or what he's given them
well we're not gonna go down that road
what other stories do we have today it's
Friday I'm having fun and it's the
weekend
it's the weekend
the weekend is coming I can't believe
it's already January 20th January 20th
2023 this is the anniversary the
two-year anniversary of Joe Biden being
sworn in
uh the the deep dark Q Anon web says
something big is gonna happen today oh
something big hey guess what q and
honors your orange Mussolini Jesus had
to drop his lawsuit with Tiss James
because yesterday he was sanctioned
because he's he's trying to trying to
press lies in federal court
the same lies he's grifting off you and
again what's funny
what's funny is this [__]
grifted these dumb sons of [__] out
there
who believe this delusional stuff that
they're that are mind [__] by Q Anon
he grifted them into giving him legal
funds because the election was being
stolen then he he gripped at them for
legal funds to bring a lawsuit against
Hillary Clinton because she tried to
steal the 2016 election
now he's gonna grift him for the money
that he owes because it's a frivolous
lawsuit and it's a bunch of [__] lies
and the federal judges issued sanctions
on him and his attorney
to pay these [__] fines that equal
almost a million dollars he's gonna
grift them for that money too
when does it end with you people when
will you get it
when will you understand
that the entire apparatus around Trump
not just Trump himself
but his allies the the Trump right-wing
media Newsmax oan Fox News right wing
talk radio it's all built to grift your
dumb asses
to delude you to feed you lies
and make you puke up your money
that's that's what it's designed to do
and you're still doing it
don't you see how you're being duped
you're they're they totally don't give a
[__] about you that's like that's like
this whole story of this sales tax have
you heard this [__] have you heard this
[__] oh my God I I gotta go through
it now now I'm all pissed off about this
sales tax thing
have you heard this they want to do a
national sales tax 30 percent
these are the [__] concerned
about the prices of groceries are the
ones yelling and screaming that they
want to raise the price of your
groceries by 30 percent and not only
that not only that then you've got to do
all the local taxes it's not going to
get rid of that
these [__] boneheads
look sales tax
in general
sales tax on Goods is a tax on the poor
and the middle class
full stop
say listen to when I say this again
sales tax in general
is a tax on the poor and the middle
class
you think that some [__] billionaire
is gonna be is is gonna consume more
[__] that they're gonna pay sales tax on
this is it this is by Design to do two
different well three different things
number one make sure billionaires the
top one percent pay nothing in tax
nothing
he don't think they're gonna get tax
exempt status somehow some way
through some shell company that owns a
religion or some stupid [__]
that you're not going to be able to do
so you can buy milk
they're get they don't want to pay taxes
they don't think they should give the
government their money we should be
appreciative that they make gazillions
of dollars every year and that they're
great
and we shouldn't want a nickel of it
they think we should pay for it all of
it
and the biggest percentage of our
[__] income 30 percent is what they
want to raise the prices of groceries
literally the Republican Party
in the House of Representatives is
saying right now we want a 30 sales tax
so we can raise the price of your
groceries by 30 because we think that's
fair
it's fair that you pay all the taxes
it's fair that you pay all the revenue
and the rich folks don't have to pay
anything
we have a progressive income tax now I
don't even know that and then we have
capital gains I don't even know that
it's very Progressive
well sorta
depends on who's the [__] president
who's in Congress and who's given all
the [__] tax cuts away to the [__]
wealthy and redistributing wealth to
them
listen that GDP is not all theirs
it's our country too
that GDP is ours we are the government
we are the country [__] them they don't
the one percent do not own that GDP just
because they're the ones who have all
the [__] capital and all the money
how much how how much of a GDP would
those bastards have if we didn't trade
our labor to them huh how much you
[__] would speak into that uh
the tech tech industry is [__]
dropping jobs like crazy we might talk
about that today too
they're trying to find more ways to be
profitable in one way
is to [__] to [__] Americans that's what
it is to [__] middle class and poor
Americans just [__] them that [__] them
and [__] them
but Republicans in the House of
Representatives
want to have a sales tax that's 30
percent
think about when you go in now and
you're figuring up sales tax
and then imagine
that the people who say inflation is the
number one issue oh my God we gotta help
inflation even though we're not going to
vote on anything that helps inflation
we're not going to do anything that
helps inflation actually what we want to
do is the exact opposite we want to
inflate inflate the prices of all your
goods and all your services by 30
percent
they literally ran on dropping inflation
and they're gonna inflate everything
that's their idea
there are some states that don't even
have a sales tax I don't know if some of
you are out there who live in States who
don't have sales tax
can you imagine living in a state that
doesn't have sales tax
and you elected a republican in your
district and that [__] is like
yeah we wanna we wanna make sure you
work till you're 70 because you're gonna
need it you're gonna need it for the 30
sales tax we're gonna put on everything
you [__] piece of [__] that's
literally what they're saying hey we
want you to work longer
we want you to work well into your 70s
you're gonna need to
because you're gonna have to pay that 30
sales tax because we're going to make
sure that the rich in this country don't
pay a goddamn dime towards it and that
they get to keep all the GDP the
entirety of it the whole [__]
they get to keep it
because we love the rich when did we
start loving the [__] rich in this
country when when did we start idolizing
when did we start making them
superheroes [__] them
[__] them I love the phrase Eat the Rich
but they are not they listen they are
not [__] superheroes I am sick and
tired of people telling me what the how
[__] smart they are how intelligent
they know they are not
there's a prime example going on right
now in this country as Elon Musk the
richest man in the world isn't the
richest man in the world anymore because
he's a dumb [__]
he lives off us you know that right
the entirety of Elon musk's success the
the reason why on paper he was the
richest man in the world in the first
place is because of our tax dollars
that's right us we the people the
government
that he [__] hates that he doesn't
want to pay taxes to
capitulates to all the Q Anon conspiracy
theories about the government in the
Deep state
and this stupid [__] Twitter files
idea
he's bearing bearing two companies
destroying them absolutely destroying
them
and he's smart
and we're supposed to believe that if we
just give him if we just give him more
tax cuts then we'll have it better get
the [__] out of here with that nonsense
and then we're supposed to believe that
a 30 sales tax is gonna fix that problem
not exacerbated get the [__] out of here
go talk to anyone you know I don't give
a [__] what hat they got on Whose flag
they got flying on the back of their
[__] big ass stupid truck I don't
care what bumper stickers they got what
Q Anon conspiracy theories they believe
in go ask them if they want to pay a 30
sales tax go do it ask them
the most deluded maybe one or two be
like oh yeah it's a good idea because
because the Republicans say it's a good
idea so it's a good idea I don't know
why it's a good idea I can't use logic
or Reason to figure out how they're
taxing the poor in the middle class and
not taxing the rich but it's a good idea
but most people are getting like [__]
you I don't want to pay 30 sales tax
what are you crazy
most people don't like paying the sales
tax that they have now and most the time
the majority of the tax that you pay in
sales tax in a lot of states is local
that's how local governments run is
sales tax
I don't know if you know that you
[__] your [__] geniuses
but even then even then running local
governments
sales tax really is kind of a
bone-headed way of funding them
because you're just taxing at a higher
percentage of income
of the poorest in the [__] in the
[__] community
so you're only making them
poorer
and you wonder why you're all your
[__] white privileged friends are
like yeah you had all these pores
everywhere oh man homeless people why
can't they afford housing
because they gotta pay [__] you
you're going to be able to afford a
[__] dwelling and you think they're
gonna stop at 30 percent really you
think you think you think
that these Republicans if they would get
what they want what you're not going to
get this but we have to politicize it we
have to you think if they get what they
want they're not going to raise this
[__] to 35 40 45 50.
oh they're gonna love the [__] out of
them taxing poor people you [__]
ain't right Republicans love love to tax
[__] poor people no question about
that at all
Hondo persento they love taxing them to
[__] poor people
so once they get a taste of it boy they
won't be able to stop
but think about this I mean again this
is not going to be reality because
there's no way Democrats in the Senate
are going to take up this bill there's
no way that Joe Biden who has done as a
president has done more for the American
people as far as legislation is
concerned than any modern president I
don't give a [__] what you say challenge
me let's do it I'll debate your ass on
the list of things that that guy's
accomplished holy [__] for the American
people
you think that guy is gonna sign a bill
that is basically and one vowel stroke
gonna [__] gonna make the majority of
America poorer
and the party that was bitching about
inflation and milk prices and how much
you're gonna spend under Joe bed
Democrats are going to make you spend
all your income oh my God they're gonna
make you go broke this country's going
to hell in a handbasket and here they
are here they are we're not even [__]
three weeks into this year into this
Congress
hell we almost went longer voting for
The Speaker of the House than we've gone
for them from we don't want inflation to
Let's inflate everything 30 percent
because that's essentially what they're
doing
that's what they're doing
if you're out there and you're you're in
a in a position in your tax situation
where you are paying very little of your
income
or you're getting tax credits
because that's what the ultimate one
that's the other thing that they want to
do they want to tax the poor they want
to make sure that billionaires and the
richest one percent don't pay taxes but
they want to get rid of the IRS
they want to get rid of the difficult
tax code I mean it served them for a
long time they love it but boy wouldn't
it be great if we could just tax
everyone else and not tax us at all and
there was no agency to hold us
accountable to that
why what do you think the old fake ass
87 000 IRS agents [__] was it wasn't
it wasn't reality it was they're scared
that the IRS is going to hire people and
have enough funding to hold the richest
one percent to account of how much taxes
they [__] know
and make sure they pay that [__] to us
the government us it's us you
[__] we're the government
we drive on the roads we use the roads
we use the [__] Telecom system we use
the electrical Grid in the power grid
we use the infrastructure we have we the
people have to pay for it somehow and
the people who benefit the most off of
it
should pay the most
it's not difficult to understand this
not the opposite way around
just go ask your friends and your family
especially your manga friends and family
do not leave them out of this
conversation holy [__]
watch their goddamn head spin and heads
explode
as they try to talk their way out of
making sure that their [__] their milk
is 30 percent more that their groceries
that their [__] they buy at Walmart is
30 more go ask them go tell them see
what they think
see what they think about that 30 tax
that the people they voted for and they
encourage because they love
authoritarianism and God they love
Christianity guns and gas stoves
go ask them go ask them you want to pay
30 more you stupid [__] you voted for it
you and you you tell them you voted for
it you voted for these schlubs
this is what we deliver here at the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific two full hours two
full hours we're gonna have bonehead at
the top of the hour for the second hour
of the show we got a special guest
coming to talk to us
about the frivolous lawsuit case and why
tis James
um may have may have won a battle here
of of her loss the lawsuit getting
dropped against her so don't forget to
subscribe right here at the Tony
Michaels podcast you're not going to
want to miss a single Friday on bonehead
you're not going to want to miss a
single day and we're trying to get the
20 000 hour goal as 20 000 subscribers
right now that's our current goal and
you can do me a huge favor
not only can you subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast here on YouTube but
share it with three friends
and get them to subscribe it's very
important and that's where you vote for
bonehead of the week on the community
tab so if you're on another platform
right now get over to YouTube get in the
chat to see our moderators they'll tell
you all the details they'll tell they'll
tell you they'll tell you but go
to the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
subscribe but share it with three of
your friends and get them to share it
with three of their friends they're
definitely going to want to see this
first segment on the 30 sales tax
everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Friday Friday Friday
got some videos I want to show you here
um we were talking about Rhonda santis
earlier
and why Rhonda Santos is doing what
Rhonda Santos is doing Banning books
they want to burn them
they want to get rid of the truth they
don't want to teach children the truth
they don't want to they definitely don't
want to teach them about the plight of
African Americans in this country God
damn they just they just might know the
truth and they just might know that the
lies that their racist [__] parents
and grandparents are telling them are
actually [__] lies hmm
you want to know where it comes from
I mean Rhonda Santos is doing this he's
the governor right but I'm going to show
you here in the [__] list Roundup
of where this is coming from
I got proof
right wing watch has it on their Twitter
page
assistant I mean Rhonda santis is a
[__] racist
there's no way that anyone
who isn't a racist wouldn't do this type
of [__]
and say these type of things and go
along with this [__] Nazism they're
[__] America First Nazi party folks
I've been telling you that
but where are they getting these ideas
where are they getting these ideas where
in history did they get these ideas from
well let me show you the shitless
Roundup because we round up all the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends
let's start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
tweets and the trendy trends like I said
I got a clip for here we're gonna get
into it because we got to do bonehead of
the week
at the top of the hour we got a special
guest joining us
um for bonehead of the week so we're
going to um which I don't think we've
ever done before Oh yeah and I honestly
don't think we've had a guest on bonetta
WE but she's gonna break down she's
gonna break down the
the Haba story of a million dollar
sanctions and the update with the
lawsuit that that same lawyer and law
firm with Trump has dropped against Tish
James the Attorney General of New York
who has a civil case against the Trump
organization it's in receivership
now because of that so
but I want to go straight to
um the Twitter feed here this is from
right wing watch uh I said to this
comment if you're wondering where their
idea book Banning came from if you just
if you're wondering you know if you
gotta if you're like oh where
where did they get they get this idea of
being burning lips
and how are why are they using the lgbtq
community and their hatred
to ban such books well we're gonna find
out where they got this [__] idea and
where they're excited about it by the
way
oh these right Wingers are excited about
it
and this is this is where Rhonda santis
is getting his education 101
on who has the best ideas in history
to kill the truth okay uh right wing
watch has if you're not following
right-wing watch you you need to so go
follow right wing watch on Twitter if
you're not already
but they posted this video and and said
white nationalist Christian fascist
Dalton
Claude felter
[Music]
Dalton is his name oh my God
can you get more beta than that uh
Dalton here declares that he doesn't
have quote any hate in his heart for
Nazis well isn't that convenient
isn't it convenient that this little
[__] has no hate in his heart
for Nazis
hmm
you see where this is going
oh yeah
goes on to say and proclaims that
burning
quote sexually degenerate books
is an example of something quote
positive that Nazis brought to the table
in Germany in the 1930s and the 1940s
now we're going to listen to this
disgusting drivel and the reason why
folks is because we don't look away here
at the Tony Michaels podcast as a matter
of fact we believe that sunlight is the
best disinfectant and we're giving
sunlight to to did Ron DeSantis and why
and where and who is telling him that he
needs to ban books he needs to ban
African-American studies because it was
a good idea in Germany in the 1930s and
the 1940s and by God it was a Nazi
positive thing I don't have
so here is Dalton the white Christian
nationalist the tale that Wags the dog
you got it this is the tail that is
wagging the dog let's listen to this
Tail Wag
I don't have any hate in my heart for
Nazis I don't have any hate my heart for
the ADL but I am very displeased with
them and I don't like them because they
persecute against me
and the splc
who doxes my friend's parents addresses
in order to strike fear into the family
those people are having a direct effect
on me so when I ask you is there
anything positive that the Nazis brought
to the table to Germany
in the 30s and 40s
I think an obvious answer would be the
book burning of sexual degeneracy the
the books that describe sexual acts with
adult content and being
okay there you go and of course there's
more to it we're going to listen to it
here
but Dalton here this white Christian
nationalist you know you think oh well
he's a nobody right ah he's nobody no
big deal no one's heard of this guy
that's the exact problem
because again folks this is the tail
that is wagging the dog
they they went to bed with these
[__] folks
the Republican Party decided that they
would sell out their power to these
[__] alt-right right wing America
First Nazis
and we watched weeks ago as Kanye West
destroyed himself
by doing the exact same thing
that Dalton is doing here hailing Hitler
ah man he's such a great guy so smart he
was intelligent
I love Hitler
is what Kanye West said
now they're making this popular not just
amongst the few
the neo-nazis and the crazies and the Q
anonas out there they're making this
popular in the United States House of
Representatives
this idea of white replacement
this idea that the LGBT community is
trying to descend the American society
down down into the dirt so that they can
make it their own and take over what the
[__] are you talking about
that they're using that they're using
that they're using truth about humans
in some way to to degrade society when
it's the [__] truth
but these people are terrified of the
truth they're terrified of it and a lot
of times they're terrified of their own
truth
because I would love to see I would love
to see
Dalton's here search history that's what
I would love to see oh baby I bet it's a
[__] doozy oh man I bet Dalton's
search history is just riddled full of
sexual
degeneration
you [__] little scab you little [__]
Dalton
you scummy [__]
wondering what it was
what it was that the Nazis did great ah
what they did great oh man they did so
many things oh they did great things
you [__] piece of [__]
let's let's keep listening to the tail
that is wagging the DeSantis dog beams
here's the here's the crazy thing about
Germany in the 1930s 20s 30s and 40s
these books were not being given to
children
and they still thought that it was evil
they still thought that it was
destroying German culture and Society
in America today
how'd that work out for 1920s 1930s and
1940s
Germany
Dalton
how'd that work out for him
did you read did you read the other book
that you were supposed to read or did
you miss the book
on the Second World War
and the Holocaust
and murdering
six million Jewish people
Dalton you [__] you [__] piece of
[__]
did you miss that book or did you burn
that one because it offends you because
it tells the truth
huh are you offended by the truth Dalton
is that what it is are you such a
[__] snowflake
that you can't handle the [__] truth
that you can't you can't understand that
the books that you're wanting to ban
are the same way they deluded the German
population in the 1930s and the 1940s in
Germany you dumb [__] it ain't
about the what's in the books it's about
hating the people that are in the books
you [__]
it's about hating the existence of the
that the the books of of that are about
those people why do you think Rhonda
santis
is wanting to ban African-American
studies why why do you think it ain't
about it ain't about the [__] books
or what is said it's about the hatred
that they have for that marginalized
group of people
and because the Republican parties have
decided to have
cocaine sex orgies with neo-nazis
this is what you get these are the
babies that you produce when you [__]
Nazis
people
this is our [__] around and find
outstage when we allow this [__] to
continue
when we vote these [__] America First
Nazis into power when we give them just
an Inkling
that they have some sort of say over our
governments whether it be federal state
or local
and this is the tail that is wagging the
America First Nazi Republican party dog
this is it you're watching it Dalton
here these books
are given to children and not only given
to children but promoted to children
said that this is the right way to look
at life everything is about sex we need
to worship Sex Is Our God these people
can't stop thinking about [__]
genitalia and sex they can't stop
almost every single one of these books
talks about people's identity not their
sexuality
just because you [__] sickos
on the right believe that someone's
identity is only sexual when it is not
CIS and white
you're the [__] degenerates you're
the ones who are the [__] molesters
you are the predators when you don't
understand that identity isn't
exclusively tied to sexuality
especially if it's not CIS and white you
[__] sick bastards
to think that someone's identity because
they're a bipoc person or an lgbtq
Community member is somehow inherently
tied to sexuality is not only delusional
but it's a [__] lie and it's
dangerous
you're gonna get [__] killed
and you're convincing people to be Nazis
and there's nothing good about banning
books I don't give a [__] what it is I
don't even care if it's [__] porno I
don't care if it's the Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn because it has the
n-word in it
when you go down the road of banning
books and not letting people know
the truth
you start Banning African-American
studies
you start wiping out the existence of
History
that defines us whether it is good or it
is bad but we must know the truth
and when you erode at the truth you
erode at your Liberty in society
because if we have the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people
that's not Liberty Dalton you piece of
trash
I should be
more upset than the German people in
1930. I think that's reasonable
the Nazis were right about this and you
can put that the Nazis were right about
burning sexually degenerate material
that could have that at their time could
have fallen into the hands of children
but was not being directly promoted to
children and in our society it is I
believe we should take a page out of the
Nazi book here to burn books and there
you have it you want to know you want to
know where Ron DeSantis is getting the
idea
to ban Book Fairs
to ban books in schools and to go as far
as to ban curriculum out of books
Nazi Germany
it's where he's getting the idea
that's where these ideas stem from
what do you think was the blueprint in
Nazi Germany
you think it just appeared out of
nowhere
we must not tolerate intolerance
and every measure
even as uncomfortable as it may be
especially for us white people I'm
especially for you [__] white people
out there
you must not tolerate intolerance
there is white privilege and we should
use that white privilege to smash it
into [__] pieces
because of narratives like this that can
stem from it that the idea that someone
who is different from you who is not CIS
and who is not white and their identity
automatically makes them a sexual is
sexual in any way number one but a
sexual degenerate
only calls into question
our society as a whole
and until we get to a place where we do
not have people in power listening and
projecting
the policies that Dalton here thinks
Nazi Germany did so well
which is oppress the rights of other
people
because of who they are and their
freedom for Liberty
and we have lost our way
and as we learn from Dr Martin Luther
King
as I talked about him on Monday
the moderate whites
are the danger
their complicency
is just as bad as the perpetrators
so we must not tolerate it and that
means I'm woke well [__] you Dalton I'm
woke as [__]
I'm woke as a [__] so let's do
it
let's [__] do it
all right I'm gonna move on to another
story before we go to bonehead the week
I gotta check in here and see where uh
we're at on bonehead of the week because
we have a guest coming on so I gotta
kinda
keep track
of where we're at
I gotta time it just right with the
guest
I you know this I make this look easy I
know but there's a lot of stuff going on
behind the scenes while I'm talking
especially on a Friday when we get the
bonehead of the week uh
uh if I if I'm watching news stories and
I'm not paying attention
um
[Laughter]
people sending me things in the meantime
of things that are updates
uh it could get uh
get a little chaotic over here not too
bad though I'm not complaining it just
it's part of the job I guess uh so you
just got to keep up with it but uh we're
gonna let me check in on on on Gabe
Sanchez and the bonehead of the week see
how we're doing here see if see if we're
in a position where and we can actually
no that doesn't look like we're yet
there
uh let's see let me see how much time
how much time I've got left here
again we've got a guest coming on and I
want to wait till Gabe Sanchez comes on
before I announce the guest but maybe I
just should depending on how much time
he's got left uh putting bonehead
together because we got to put this
together in the morning
oh he's he's he he just a few more
minutes just a few more minutes here
um and and we'll have this ready and
we're getting really close
and to having bonehead of the week uh
ready and if you if you guys don't know
bonehead of the week used to be a
weekend show did you know that it used
to be its own little thing we do it on
the weekends
and when we had a when we just did the
show one day a week
and then when we went to every single
weekday we went through Monday through
Friday two hours a day we placed
bonehead of the week the show we did
during the weekend as a segment
in the second hour of Friday because we
felt like the audience would want to end
the week
on a segment that they got to engage in
right I think that's why this thing is
so popular I think that's why I love it
so much is because you guys actually get
to decide we don't we don't decide who
the bone of the week is uh Gabe Sanchez
normally
he's got either the three boneheads or
two of them right in the poll
because for you out there that you don't
know we do a poll every single Thursday
sometimes it comes out late thank you
moderators for reminding us if uh we
don't get it out and quiet time
the moderators don't moderate the chat
they make sure me and Gabe Sanchez
aren't boneheads as well
um but if we we get the bonehead of the
week pull out on Thursdays on YouTube
and on Twitter make sure to subscribe
here on YouTube we're trying to get the
20 000 speaking of that you can go to
the community Tab and that's where all
those bonehead pulls are you can go
check out uh yesterday's poll and
today's bonehead of the week poll and
the previous ones on YouTube they're all
right there
and so we do a poll every week with
three contestants for bone hint of the
week
and that's how it was when it first
started
and it used to because we would do the
show on Saturday or Sunday we'd in the
poll on Friday what we used to do is
we'd put the pull out like on a Tuesday
or Wednesday but we learned very quickly
that there's too many boneheads and
there's too much bone-headed stuff
so what do I mean by that we put the
poll out on Tuesday by Friday there was
a whole nother set of boneheads like a
whole nother set of them
I mean between Tuesday and Friday these
Republican America First Nazis do so
much bone-headed [__]
that we had to move the bone-headed pole
the night before the show
that we would record it
so
when we went to uh every single weekday
and that was about a year ago I think
we're coming up on a year anniversary of
being on five days a week
but once we went to five days a week for
two full hours and we moved the
bone-headed segment our bonehead not
boneheaded
we moved the bone end of the week it is
kind of bone-headed it's fun though
that's the whole point but we moved the
bone end of the week segment to the
second hour on Fridays
uh we we did the poll on Thursday and
everything worked out great
but as the audience grew
they discovered that we weren't covering
some of the bone-headed stories that
happened that morning
so
what ended up happening is we had to add
people to the bonehead of the week that
weren't able to be voted on that we
could just add them in give them a
dishonorable mention so that's what we
call it here we give a dishonorable
mention
to a bonehead
and that allows us to make sure we can
add someone on Friday morning because
news is broke that Republicans are
boneheads and this one in particular
deserves to be on the show
so we had to do that
oh and then uh Ethan I think it's Ethan
Schmidt is that his name Gabe Sanchez
are you here yet
um Ethan Schmidt I don't know if you
know this guy he's a Kerry Lake
supporter he's a he's a [__]
chucklehead he posts tick tocks and [__]
on social media he's an idiot he's a
goddamn bigot he's a racist he's he's
he's a Christian white nationalist or at
least he pretends to be all this stuff
like the rest of them do
but Gabe Sanchez called him the alpha
cook
um on on a bonehead of bonehead of the
week segment
and was that birthed every single week
that we have the dishonorable mention
and the alpha cook of the week so not
only do you have the three contestants
that you can vote for on bonehead of the
week and we're practicing democracy here
we're practicing voting we have to keep
doing that every single week we got to
go to the ballot every single week we
gotta vote vote vote I know it seems
kind of trivial but makes sense and
you're never going to vote for these
people in the first place so why not
mock them and vote them to be the
biggest idiot or bonehead as it is in
the title
but also we had to enjoy ourselves by
getting breaking news stories and
breaking bone-headed stories so we have
the dishonorable mention and the alpha
guck
um so let's see if he's going to be
joining us
let's see let me go back okay so yeah
here he is here well here he is that's
about goddamn time
[Laughter]
I'm just making the goddamn assets man I
realized I didn't have I didn't have
um
uh yeah I didn't have pennia's face so I
had to go find a photo and there was no
photo where so I ended up having to go
oh man I had to end up find I had
internet archives the Wayback machine or
some [__] I had to go through the uh
inmate uh search at the Bernalillo
County Corrections uh
current picture of the one back in when
he was arrested and imprisoned no no
that one that one I can't find that one
I tried to find it for the what was that
couldn't find it but I did find it for
the one that he was it's not in public
record and no journals has released that
picture of his of his of his first the
only time and I and I had a hard time
finding it there's only one time when
I've seen it and it's from a local
reporter did a did a story on him when
he was running and now he was like oh
yeah I've gone to jail but I reformed
myself and did all this [__] meanwhile
he's like I'm plotting the [__] shoot
people well I see you used it looks like
an official picture of like his social
media or something is that no no that's
the one from his inmate oh really from
the from the corrections uh the
Bernalillo Corrections office I see
normally normally a booking picture is
not that not that great yeah I had to go
through I had to do some touch-ups oh I
see I see I see okay you had you touched
up Pena's photo well I had to sharpen it
a little bit and it was too bright so I
had to darken a little bit Yeah make it
make it look good see that's why that's
why we have Gabe Sanchez here is because
I just like throw [__] on there and like
yeah that looks good and you're like no
that looks like [__] like your colors
are all off the lighting's not right
yeah you'd have a thousand reasons why
what I did was [__] and he's right
he's correct he's correct everyone I get
really nervous in the mornings when I've
got to do the thumbnail when this guy
can't do it for whatever reason
and um and
when when that when that happens when
that happens I get really nervous when I
do it I even send it to you I'm like did
I do all right is it all right did it
yeah yeah you got it you did okay he
lied to him and he's like yeah
fantastic there yeah it uh it's okay
it's all right yeah it's all right it's
all right uh I want to give this the
announcement of this special guest today
um yeah so I haven't told the audience
who it's gonna be they might have been
guessed by now so when we get to the
Haba section of the bone end of the week
we're going to bring in Allison Gill a
Mueller she wrote that's right I think
we're gonna have her on because I wonder
she's tweeting about this morning she
was following the story yesterday I mean
she's been following the story of the
frivolous lawsuits that Trump has not
only tried to sue Hillary Clinton I
think it's like 30 or some other people
we're gonna ask her right yeah right
well there's also there's also an update
yeah the tis James that's what I'm
wanting and she tweeted about this
morning so I I messaged her I said hey
you want to come on you want to you want
to talk about it she said yeah great the
[__] doesn't have any money man no
yeah he's like oh [__] well you know
what's funny is I told the audience
earlier so he
he
he's literally done this to himself he
had the big line he had he had to raise
money for legal funds on the big lie
they stole it from him he never really
paid the attorneys they all lost their
[__] law license yeah because they
were doing that's like that's like a
George Santos move right there right
right
everyone thinks George Santos again is
some sort of outlier and he's the
inventor of fraud like are you kidding
me
Donald Trump is the O.G Santos okay he's
the OG don't you see it and then then
this is gets even better he he I know he
griffs to fundraise money to sue Hillary
Clinton right because he's you know yeah
yeah crooked Hillary we got a steward
for all her lies and how she tried to
steal the election from me in 2016 right
yeah they spied out my campaign right
they spied on my campaign so so he so he
grips money from them to have this
lawsuit and then when the judges well
when the lawsuit gets thrown out in the
the defendants in the case are like no
we're gonna [__] file sanctions
against you we want our [__] money
back this is ridiculous what's like 31
defendants right right yeah 30 30. I
don't know if it's 30 with Hillary or
31.
she's leaving the charger there's a lot
of [__] people though that want their
[__] money back though right that's
this that's the that's the story here is
there's a lot of people that want their
[__] money back yeah and and so and
probably some of them can't afford it
without like they can't it's a lot of
money like they probably take money
either you know the whole thing
this is also on I mean like we can
probably you know we can get into this
and Bones yeah yeah listen to that let's
do that I don't wanna I don't want to
divulge oh okay okay well but here's
here but we're gonna have Allison gill
from Mueller
um but well we'll go over it we can
double talk this thing
this is on the heels of last week yeah
where we had you know
um it was the 2016 uh NDA lawsuit right
and just drop those so yes he's it's
loss after loss after loss it's the
biggest [__] loser ever you know
people more smallest hands biggest
losers smallest hands I know you got
them there I know he's got them smallest
hands Biggest Loser all right everyone
stick around when we come back we will
get into the bone of the week and we'll
probably just say the same [__] we just
said probably because he's right I
should have waited I should have waited
always right
we'll be right back with bone of the
week right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds the
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
the second hour on Friday
Michael's podcast we have a special
guest I believe Dave changes this is the
first gift we've ever had on bonehead
Elite I don't think we ever ran against
the week if I'm remembering correctly
that that would be correct that's the
first first yes first attempt at the
first attempt first guess here we are
do it live do it live
bone of the week what a great segment
and we got a great one for you this week
um oh yeah you know you voted for the
person don't stop coming
I I really I really believe that they
would uh vote for the person that they
voted for right like I really thought
that yeah I was gonna go down I will
hear it we
start okay Monday and Tuesday you were
like holy [__] this person is definitely
gonna win right right and I've got more
details on that investigation as well
for those wondering I'm talking about
Salomon Pena right and then no way that
that guy wasn't gonna win bonehead right
right yeah that's what we thought and
then and this is the reason why we wait
until pretty much Thursday night to like
launch the poll because then I think on
Tuesday or Wednesday we find out about
you know George Santos and the dog fraud
right and the secretary
and then that steals money
dog that died and then it was either
that night or the next day then we find
out about George Santos
and it was like it was like one after
another after another boom boom boom so
that's why I was telling the audience I
was telling the audience I said we used
to do this like on the weekend and we
would put the poll up on like Tuesday
yeah and we've discovered by the time we
got to the point where we were gonna
record this thing we're like these
aren't they people don't even remember
why these people aren't bone I mean we
have a hard time right we're like why
were they on the [__] and and most of
the time we're like oh no it it was
actually that but they've done three
wrong things
since then I mean when you've got people
like Jim Jordan and Matt Getz and Donald
Trump and Marjorie Taylor green Lauren
bobert on bone in the week if you put
him on a pole for bonehead on Monday for
something they did on Monday by Friday
they've done two or three more
bone-headed things that would give them
the ability to be a contestant on it
yeah so and there's even even today
there's been some developments on Santos
as well so it was just like it's just it
never stops it never ends with these
[__] boneheads so let's do it
bonehead of the week
foreign
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week we have a special edition Gabe
Sanchez today a bone end of the week
this is the very first time we are
making history here on the Tony Michaels
podcast this is the first time we've had
a guest on live for bone end of the week
but we have a great story for bonehead
of the week uh because of one of our
contestants that is that is some updated
news and this person has been following
this news for a time now uh I'll tell
you who the guest is it's Allison Gill
of Mueller she wrote of the Twitter
account so if you're following her uh
you should go over there and follow her
definitely to get updates on the story
she stays up to date on this stuff but
she's going to be joining us today in
the bonehead of the week segment when we
get to one of our boneheads so let's not
delay here here are our contestants this
week for bonehead of the week
representative George Santos uh or four
other names that we could have put up on
the screen to be quite honest this is
his name in Congress though this is the
name of the name in which he co-signs
bills with right right
can't say if that's the same name he
uses when he steals people's checkbooks
right or when he's right right or when
he's doing drag performances right right
well actually we know that when he
steals scarves he might go under the
name of Anthony devolder oh okay yeah
which is different from the one he uses
for the scams the check book stealing
scarves stealing veterans money dead
dogs money stealing uh just goes on and
on and on uh and then we have Solomon
Pena he's uh he's a domestic terrorist
he's a republican so of course he is why
wouldn't he be when you're in the Maga
wing of the Republican Party these days
they self-proclaim themselves in Texas
we are all domestic terrorists so why
wouldn't you be and then the I think
she's a lawyer is she still a lawyer
today I think so
um
it's a lawyer that's like the question
like how long will I have my law license
I don't know like I mean
we know that she's in the depositions I
can't say if she's an attorney right but
she certainly speaks and she's been
recording yeah
I'm a racist it's I'm a racist Haba I am
a racist taba so
we uh because we're still waiting on
Allison here let's start with Mr Pena
okay um we know that um we've been
trying to stay up to speed here on the
show and Gabe you've been keeping us up
to speed on this story you've been
following it the entire time but is
there any updates there is okay so what
is the update in the Maga domestic
terrorist Solomon Pena story all right
so just to catch everyone up the the
quick and dirty of it is Solomon Pena
this failed wannabe New Mexico state
legislator
uh lost his election lost it bigly lost
it by like 48 or something like that in
New Mexico right every single Precinct
in his district 14 in New Mexico huge
loss wasn't going to win it 75 of the
time it goes Democrat and only 16
percent of people registered that are in
that area are Republican so just on
those numbers alone it was never going
to happen but you know what hey dream
big you know dream big
so what happens is we find out that
there are these four shootings that have
happened from
from December and into January and then
this week we realized that oh it was
actually this guy Salman Pena and he was
hiring these people to shoot at the
homes now this and later in the week we
also discovered through a confidential
witness that Not only was he upset that
they were shooting too high in the
dwellings of the house
that they were shooting too late so he
wanted them to shoot lower and shoot
earlier in the evening to make sure that
people were shot right so right now he
just has charges of shooting at dwelling
shooting out of a motor vehicle being a
felon and that's if people don't know he
was a felon or an ex-con uh he went to
prison for seven years came out was on
probation and then right after he was uh
the probation was lifted then he ran for
office and then lost the race
super triggered election denial
all of that stuff big big Trumper
so then we find out this week later in
the week that uh he was upset that the
people weren't being hit so this guy's
gonna get a [__] attempted murder
charge 100 if you have intent to harm
someone
and there is proof you know he's paying
people there's a conspiracy around this
in terms of what he's done
the guy's [__] they're gonna throw the
book at this guy now what we've learned
as of yesterday which I was luckily able
to throw in there now as I was tracking
the finances this week I noticed some
people that were kind of they were
raising some red flags right one of the
high donors the top donors to Penny's
campaign was Jose Trujillo which is one
of the people that was involved in the
shooting that got pulled over had 800
laced fentanyl pills in the car as long
as as well as a Glock and an AR gun okay
and this is again I know I know this is
uh this is where LED law enforcement to
knowing this was the people who were
doing these things right because they
matched they match the bullet casings to
the casings that were left in the homes
of these Democratic elected officials
this guy Solomon penny is a stage five
Clinger okay he showed up to these
houses we have footage of him showing up
to these houses trying to be like hey I
believe we should not
uh go through with with
uh actually
uh certifying this election it was
rigged it was rigged you're a [__] all
this [__] okay
anyway so as you go through the finances
you realize that one of the people that
Jose Trujillo
the second person on there is this this
piece of [__] Michael Fletcher who's a
white supremacist uh he plowed through a
group of people in September 2020 at a
Brianna Taylor
um event that was celebrating her life
another guy who maxed out five thousand
who is now who now is claiming oh well I
just donate to a bunch of Republicans in
the area I met him twice he seemed
intelligent playing that whole game
right that's his alibi
that guy is uh Harvey Yates Jr okay he's
the president of an oil company called
uh jalapeno Corporation right oil and
gas company in New Mexico
rich guy he sat on as the chair of the
New Mexico Republican committee he also
was a national committeeman for the RNC
so we've got top top people here that
are involved in donating money
then another person is this woman called
Melanie griego okay Melanie griego is
the mother of Jose Trujillo okay Jose
you're starting to see a picture of the
finances huh right so we're connecting
this down now what we've also learned is
that Melanie griego lives on government
assistance from the county she lives in
a trailer park on the east side or the
west side of of the county
she doesn't have the ability to donate
four thousand dollars exactly to Solomon
Penny have you with us we got Jose
Trujillo the sun donating I think
upwards of five thousand dollars in
total uh we've got Melanie griego
donating four thousand dollars right so
again she doesn't have the money she's
living on government assistance and uh
she she is connected and then not only
that not only that but the other person
Demetrio Trujillo is Jose trujillo's
father so you've got Jose Trujillo the
sun dimitrio Trujillo the father who who
by the way they they arrested him last
week they had a search warrant on his
phone and in the phone was all the
communication between Salomon Pena
sending him the the addresses Demetrio
Trujillo looking them up in Google Maps
or Apple Maps actually then sending
those addresses the internet's a [__]
isn't it when they have sending those
over to Jose Trujillo his son to commit
these crimes because let's call it what
is these were just shooting at homes
they're only shooting at homes because
they [__] miss these people what they
attempted to do these were hired hits
this guy who's getting into the car
right now Solomon Pena was triggered a
snowflake didn't win his election denied
election denialism out the [__] ass
on this guy typical Trumper believing
only that he should win because he went
door to door is his reasoning
and then at the end of the day you find
out that this guy hired the hits of
democratic officials both former and
current Democratic officials because
they wouldn't listen to him and they
wouldn't take the documents seriously
that he was presenting which by the way
according to the former County
Commissioner Debbie O'Malley we learned
that one of the form like just the
paperwork he was sending was just
talking about just typical election
forms there wasn't anything there wasn't
any like fraud shown in here there
wasn't anything crazy that was there was
like a drop in wait what you're saying
he had no proof of election fraud and he
was it was all theories like Rudy
Giuliani does a bunch of theories seems
Seems like a pattern so now he's being
investigated for funneling Drug Money
that's what I was just going to ask is
that is that what they're suspecting is
that he was giving these donors he was
giving them money right because you
found a way into the campaign sounds
like uh I don't know a laundering scheme
right so so basically the current
development of detectives are
investigating this but we'll call it
potential but most likely is if you've
got a woman who has government
assistance and is the mother of the guy
who was just caught drug trafficking and
on firearm charges from the guns that
were used in the shooting that Pena
hired him to do right
you begin to see there's a there there's
a Republicans are the best of people
they really
know oh yeah they're the Santos of
people let me tell you they're the
Santos to people oh man and Pena Pena
here is oh man yeah you talk about a
Santos type character let me let me tell
you something
it feels like to me and I hope uh
Allison joins us yeah Allison is joining
us here and maybe maybe um because I
know I brought her for the Haba story
but we're talking about the uh Santos
aren't excuse the Pena I'm getting these
people confused they're all the same
it's all the same time
all fakes all kinds they might we might
as well we might as well just have them
all be the same but this pina story
where it seems like he's laundering
money
um through campaigns now we announced
here on the show that these charges that
they brought were state charges they're
not federal charges because there's no
federal domestic terrorism statute that
they can that they can charge him with
from what I can tell I'm no [__]
lawyer though but here's the thing it
sounds like to me um and Allison tell us
um if we're if I'm uh off my rocker here
but it sounds like to me that
if Pena welcome by the way you're our
first guest on this segment bonehead of
the week
um here ever so it's so welcome to
bonehead of the week but thank you my
question is this I know we're going to
get to The Habit story here really
quickly but it just brings up a thing in
my mind that if this is a Monday
laundering scheme where he's trying to
launder drug money through a uh campaign
couldn't that be federal charges I mean
these are federal charges that could be
brought so he could be find himself in
the United States uh Courthouse as
opposed to a state Courthouse am I
correct there I mean maybe I'm off my my
um my my skids a bit there nope you've
got it uh I mean there are federal
crimes there are State crimes some and
we've seen this uh in the fonnie Willis
versus Jack Smith investigations too
right and we've seen it uh in California
we've seen it in New Mexico now I mean
we see it everywhere where the state
goes in for example the guy who broke
into Nancy Pelosi's house and assaulted
Paul Pelosi lots of State charges but
there's also Federal invest litigation
and they kind of fill in the gaps of
each other as far as that goes and so
they're you know oftentimes the feds are
usually out front of these things like I
thought for sure in the tax fraud the
Donald Trump trump organization tax
fraud scheme the IRS and the FEDS would
have brought tax fraud charges before
the Manhattan district attorney brought
tax fraud charges but that's not how
that happened and that could have been
because Trump had one of his really good
friends in as the commissioner of the
IRS Charles Reddick who didn't leave
until just this past November so that
might have gummed up the works a little
bit but yeah that might have been the
line between A and B is what you're
saying well I don't know if you know
about the bonehead of the week segment
but we have a poll every week and these
are our contestants today and we just
went through uh Mr Pena and his
bone-headedness why he was on the
bonehead of the week poll but there's an
attorney on here and you were tweeting
about this story this morning and
there's been developments in it um
because last night we found out that um
Miss Haba the attorney for Donald Trump
in the lawsuit against Hillary Clinton
and I believe it's 30 other people but I
hope you can educate us on this she made
her way on bonehead of the week here
um and that's why I wanted to have you
on the show to tell us and give us the
rundown of what's going on because uh
this story is developing as we're pretty
much on the air here so am I got that do
we have this wrong is it 30 people with
Hillary are 30 people plus Hillary in
this lawsuit that they got these
sanctions on tell us about that yep
total 31 people Hillary is one of them
uh and there are 30 other defendants
um besides Hillary Clinton and and uh
the basic rundown is is that you know a
while ago Donald Trump decided to put
this lawsuit together to sue Hillary the
oars uh McCabe Pete strzok uh any Comey
anybody who investigated him in the in
the right any buzzword name right any
buzzword name that is any any trending
topic on Twitter and Google he was like
that's a good one I'll take that yeah
let's throw that one in why not yeah and
he he was basically uh didn't really
have any cause of action he was just it
was a big political gripe that Russia
was a hoax and they were trying to take
me down in the 2016 election even though
he won the 2016 election so there's
really no harm here and there's like
what what is he seeking there was
nothing legal about it and haba's firm
put that lawsuit together and it was
absolute Rush rubbish and Russia
Russia it kind of go hand in hand don't
they so so
um so he filed that lawsuit he went
judge shopping uh he went down and filed
in uh that's a typical Trump move there
mayor judge Eileen Cannon is and he also
shopped his lawsuit to get the special
Master appointed and he actually ended
up getting Eileen cannon in the special
master case in the in the classified
documents case but he drew judge middle
Brooks instead which they're randomly
assigned right and middlebrook's got
this case and basically uh you know
dismissed it and said you guys by the
way Hillary at all you should file
sanctions and they did and that
yesterday well about a month and a half
ago one of the defendants was awarded
about 65 000 to you know fifteen
thousand for lawyers fees and 50 000
fine for the court sanctions so this was
this was the sanction the first
sanctions not this last portion of
almost a million dollars is that what
you're saying yeah yeah and yesterday he
tacked on 937 thousand dollars to that
amount and so we're almost at exactly a
million bucks I mean we're really close
I feel like we could call this a movie I
feel like you know it's like when you
check out and they're like would you
like to round up for this organization
let's just round it up yeah you know you
could do that whole pay yourself for
with the wallet thing right when you buy
something at the grocery store and they
they give the change in your savings
account so maybe what is what we do is
just making a million bucks they can put
it in a savings account for maybe maybe
future sanctions that they'll have I
mean I don't know I don't know because
that's the breaking news what's extra
hilarious is that the same day that
first guy was awarded sanctions of about
you know 60 something thousand dollars
he went judge shopping again and filed a
lawsuit against Leticia James of New
York the New York attorney general and
he was trying to get judge Eileen Cannon
and again he ended up with Middlebrooks
and I laughed and I laughed and I said
that day a couple months ago I'm like
you might want to drop that lawsuit
uh because you're going to get hit with
more sanctions in the Hillary suit
and lo and behold yesterday they were
hit with a million bucks almost a
million dollars in sanctions and
and
I said wow now Alina Haba will you drop
your Leticia James lawsuit yeah here's
the Tweet um from 15 hours ago you said
uh yeah Abba might want to drop the suit
before they're hit with more sanctions
that was you laughing apparently and
then uh this morning this morning your
wish came true and by the way happy
birthday because what a birthday oh
happy birthday yeah yeah I didn't know
that until I went to your your page this
morning and the balloons came up and I
read that you were talking about
yourself happy birthday this is a great
birthday gift for you correct it's a
wonderful it's a wonderful birthday
present it was a nice 15 hour you were
like waiting for it and then you were
giving it this morning you know yeah it
took 12 hours
um but uh yeah they withdrew their
lawsuit uh against James they didn't say
why but I think it's pretty clear and
you know what's interesting is the
million dollars isn't just for Alina
Haba it is severally against Donald
Trump and Elena Haba and the judge said
y'all can figure out how much each of
you are going to pay so the judges and
the judge isn't defining who has to pay
what amount he's like you just got to
pay it I don't care my guess is my guess
is here that you're gonna tweet about
this soon on uh the Mueller she wrote
account
um I just maybe you can correct me if
I'm wrong I bet you're gonna tweet
something that Donald Trump is not is
going to try to get out of paying every
single penny of this almost a million
dollars would be my guess and and
they're probably going to be proved
correct I've actually already tweeted at
Alina Haba though
[Laughter]
um that that would not be a frivolous
lawsuit that would actually probably be
one that has Merit and that a judge
maybe maybe she could get Canon maybe
she could get canon in that case who
knows she probably doesn't know how to
file a
lawsuits oh man
I said hey I'm you know I'm not a lawyer
but you might want to think about filing
suit against Donald Trump to ensure that
he pays his fair share of those
sanctions otherwise you're going to get
left holding the bag you and your firm
because they can they can you know
garnish the firm uh that she belongs to
uh well and that's what I was just going
to ask so if let's say Donald Trump
tells Haba you know where to stick it
which he does every single attorney that
he has almost unless they get their
payment up front
um
and and they end up losing their loan
license so is there a situation here
where if she doesn't pay this or the
firm doesn't pay this is her law license
at risk here at all I mean this is a
typical story line with Donald Trump but
do we know if Alina Haba even
um will be a will be what she's I mean
if you consider her a lawyer now but
will she be a lawyer in the future
um if she can't afford to pay this
million dollars because I know how Boris
bar associations work sometimes if
you're sanctioned like this and you
can't pay it they won't allow you to
practice law is that correct
yeah and even if she does pay it she's
in her law licenses in Jeopardy uh it
just takes a really long time and it
would be up to Hillary at all and her
their law firms and their lawyers to
file for
um a bar review right other other types
of sanctions uh besides just monetary
and that takes a really long time look
we know Rudy Giuliani is still being
investigated by the New York Bar
although his law license has been
suspended in New York and D.C meaning he
can't practice until that review is done
yeah and probably not even after that
because what happened is they sat down
with their big they're like all right
let's start investigating and they
opened up the first page and went can I
swear on this show
yeah absolutely [__] yeah Hells to the
yeah
they opened up the first page and went
holy [__] this is so bad and he is so
egregious and he is so terrible we need
to suspend his law license now pending
the outcome of this investigation
normally you investigate and then decide
whether you're going to suspend
somebody's law license but they were
like this is so bad we have to suspend
it pending this investigation and that
investigation is still ongoing he's had
his hearing but that's how long it takes
it can take a couple of years for a bar
association to remove somebody's wild
license but I see a similar future for
early nahaba if you know if they sit
down to investigate and open up the
first page and go holy [__] she's
terrible we have to suspend her law
license pending the outcome of this
investigation I think we could see that
too but uh she doesn't even have to miss
paying that million dollars for that to
happen she just has to be a terrible
horrible awful no good lawyer which she
is well I mean there's a whole list of
these uh horrible awful no good lawyers
that Donald Trump uh Associates he seems
to be he collects a miss
absolutely insane even the person who is
not a lawyer of or a legal stature who
is watching is like this is [__]
ridiculous what is what is going on I
mean does it really take a good lawyer
to understand how how un on lawyer like
these people are it doesn't really right
I mean I'm not a lawyer and I I can see
it so well the thing that gets me one
one more thing before we go that I want
you to comment on because I think this
is the most mockable part of all this
other than just Haba is is walked into
uh traps here with Trump
um by putting herself in Jeopardy and
her long license in Jeopardy by even
associating with him
um
but we know Donald Trump has grifted for
legal funds before so and I would
imagine that Gabe Sanchez he gets the
emails like the hey give me the thing
and I'll do the 10x thing and you know
he tries to keep track of it yeah I
don't get I luckily don't get emails I
get a bunch of text messages
text messages that's what it is that's
what it is because he wants to keep up
with the Griff that's going on but my
question to the Grift is and this is a
hilarious part to me because I'm sure
there are there are emails there are
text messages there's some stuff out
there that shows that Donald Trump was
grifting for legal funds to sue Hillary
right
now he he did the frivolous lawsuit with
his supporters money and they threw it
out and now they are sanctioned to pay a
million dollars he's probably not going
to pay a nickel he'll make Kaba pay at
all but my guess is my guess is if it
hasn't happened already there is already
a grift email or already a grip text
message asking to pay the Deep States uh
fines on him that are the million
dollars and he's going to grift his
supporters for this million dollars
which he will keep the million dollars
he will not pay he'll probably make I
mean have a pay I mean this is a trump
um thing you know he is the OG Santos as
we call him here on the Tony Michaels
podcast he's the OG Santos so what do
you think do you think we're already in
a position where he's using this to
grift money I mean this is this is the
biggest joke
um that is of the Trump universe but do
you think he's already using this loss
that he has because he is the biggest
loser and to grift his supporters at
this point I mean
he might but that would be a an
exceedingly bad idea not that he hasn't
taken on exceedingly bad ideas before
but he is now we have learned he is now
currently under criminal investigation
by the new special counsel Jack Smith
specifically around the subpoenas went
out asking about the money raised on the
big lie and what it's being spent on uh
and whether or not it's being spent on
lawyers for Witnesses against him in
other investigations uh like pasentino
who used to represent Cassidy Hutchinson
for example until she went you [__]
don't care about me you're fired and got
a new lawyer and then testified
truthfully uh or fully I should say
because she didn't really lie she just
sort of was told to say she couldn't
recall things so Trump was raising money
off the big lie to pay lawyers to tell
people to
suborny to lie to the grand jury or to
the 16 committee so we also found out
with the one six committee that there
was a legal defense fund that never even
existed in the first place it wasn't
even real exactly what I'm talking
entity right yeah it was created the day
after the election before Joe Biden was
declared the winner it raised 250
million dollars so it would behoove
Trump not to take a million dollars of
that fraudulent fraudulently raised
money and spend it on this sanctions
fine oh you still think he has a any of
that 250 million dollars left oh my God
you have a lot more confidence in his
finances than I do I I think he goes
through money more than he goes so at
this point do you do you know could he
could he pay
uh because he's got his save America
pack right and then he's it's all a
shell game he's got another one that he
made right after right before the
midterms and then he made another one
that was like literally right before and
he's moving money around obviously
because there's a whole idea of like oh
well I can I can I can absorb one into
the other and then I can use it for
personal reasons and not actually have
it to use it for the midterms like I
promised I was gonna do so can he use
any of that money that's in the save
America pack to pay off this one million
dollars no he can't okay they're
beautiful no he'll try probably but yeah
I mean it's just like Santos using a
501c3 to raise money for a pack and then
paying devolder and then having a big
giant campaign donation to himself you
aren't allowed to do that it's a it's an
FEC it's campaign Finance violation and
by the way a lot of 625 000 of that
Santos money came from in Trader Victor
vexelberg's cousin who is a Russian uh
connector connected it's all it's always
wrong always rushing always Bank always
always goes back to Allison thank you
for joining us please give us a plug
here and you got anything that you want
to plug anything coming up or anything
just check out our Network mswmedia.com
and listen to the new podcast Jack it's
Andy McCabe and I and we break down the
special counsel Jack Smith investigation
uh there's a lot of new news that that's
kind of flying under the radar because
of the BS that the Legacy Media is keeps
talking about over and over again so
that would be my plug please go and
listen to subscribe to the Jack podcast
well thank you for joining us and
everyone go check out the Jack comp Jack
podcast and with you and Andrew McCabe
thank you Allison for joining us I know
I know it was quick this morning and I
appreciate your promptness on this and
and getting us um the lead on this this
Haba story so thank you very much thanks
for joining us you're the very first
guest on the bone end of the week
segment of the Tony Michaels podcast so
thank you very much thanks for joining
us we appreciate it thank you very much
and so we got the rundown there of Haba
um and in great detail there of what can
and cannot happen
um but we have some more boneheads this
week that we have to always always every
single time of course we have a winner
here and everyone knows who this winner
is but
we do have this morning
um is started a trend we started to see
this story and of course I played a
video in the beginning of the uh of the
show uh in the shitless Roundup segment
of the show
um of the tale that Wags the dog the dog
being Ron DeSantis down in Florida Gabe
Sanchez did you hear not only is Ron
DeSantis trying to ban Book Fairs in
books and math and CRT at a map I'm not
sure exactly what that means but he's
also he's also trying to ban
African-American studies so that is why
he made his way as dishonorable
mentioned today can you have you looked
into this story yet do you know I
haven't why Ron DeSantis decides to be
more racist more bigoted and more scummy
than he already is is this oh well I
mean he's told us before Florida is
where woke goes to die right right and
and what better way to kill wokeism
which by the way if no one uh remembers
his own lawyer
general counsel admitted to saying what
woke was right identifying the Injustice
that exists within our society so he
already knows what woke is it's not this
[__] propaganda that he pushes it's
not actually this whole like liberal CRT
leftist antifa [__] okay it actually
is what it is right he knows what it is
and at the end of the day Ron DeSantis
is a racist cuck who uh tries to push
and and be Trump 2.0 right and who knows
maybe he'll uh I mean he's currently
he's currently uh I don't know if he
lost but he was losing his lawsuit uh
for the 50 migrants that he sent to
Martha's Vineyard man so he's really
he's really racking up the trucks he's
racking up as well but like you you
gotta remember you think this wait wait
do you think this is a competition in
the Republican party of who like you
know the show The Biggest Loser yeah is
that is that what they're trying to do
is recreate I mean no just in a
different form and fashion than and you
lose weight yeah it's it's political
battles it's the same show but with much
worse consequences right right jail time
now I want to point out in this story
because we feature this tweet on Monday
on Martin Luther King Jr day and we call
it out national holiday yeah absolutely
I did and and it only makes sense that
it comes right back around here we are
on Friday bone of the week Rhonda Santos
is a dishonorable mention because that
[__] scumbag does not want a racist
people racist white people and their
children to learn the truth about racism
about institutional racism in this
country and and really honestly they
want to to kill the the memory of the
father of wokeness Martin Luther King Jr
and that [__] scumbag on that day had
the go to tweet happy MLK day with a
again I Have a Dream speech quote
um run that day and I I said on Monday
and you know this made piss some people
off or whatever I don't give a [__]
and here's the thing and we talked about
this I I was raised in the rural white
part of America and my image and I
didn't really realize it until the other
morning when I when I really read and
listened more than just read the letter
from the Birmingham Jail of Martin
Luther King and what he was saying and
why that letter is much more about
Martin Luther King and his mission than
maybe even I Have a Dream speech of
course we know that I have a dream
speech was such a Monumental uh point in
history the the the March and him being
there and that many people being in
Washington for equality and equity for
for black people in this country
and here's the thing
is that they have used Rhonda santis and
the white institution in this country
have used the I Have a Dream speech to
sanitize Martin Luther King but not only
that they've used this speech and
removed parts of the speech as well well
I didn't like well of course they did
they don't want African-American studies
so he doesn't even want you to learn
about the speech but here's the thing
here's what I mean more even more about
this sanitization of it because the
story is is that to to to people who did
were not born
before the 1960s especially white people
rule white people racist or right people
the Santa the the sanitizing of Martin
Luther King with the I Have a Dream
speech is this is that
black people did not have the right to
vote in the south
and they did not have the right to to to
uh to be desegregated in schools which
also was not that long ago a lot of
people a lot of people think for a lot
of these 400 years ago right like this
is crazy this was this this was that was
the last century yeah it was last
century it was like literally 40 50
years it was in the 1900s but the 1900s
wasn't that long ago you dummies but
here's the thing
is that the narrative is is that we
desegregated schools and black people
got the right to vote in the South
because Martin Luther King and he had a
dream and he fulfilled that dream and
that just is not the truth the dream is
not fulfilled the dream is not fulfilled
that was the beginning
of the fight for equality right and
equity in this country and they have
sanitized the I Have a Dream speech with
with Governor Ron DeSantis Banning
African-American studies and posting
this just days before happy MLK Day
right with a quote from the I Have a
Dream speech sanitizing it even further
that hey racism doesn't exist
institutional racism is over it was over
when he gave that speech right you can't
have it anymore Barack Obama was elected
there's no such thing as equality
inequity and by the way by the way this
land is not stolen Ron DeSantis said him
that himself right
and they sanitize they sanitize the
memory of Martin Luther King and then
they [__] they [__] on him and his
legacy when Ron DeSantis isn't
comfortable with people learning the
[__] truth and knowing what it says
in that letter from the Birmingham Jail
because I I want to tell the audience uh
please go read the I Have a Dream speech
listen to it uh even the parts that they
want to ban and they want to cancel
because there can't they are cancel
culture but please if you can go read
the letter from the Birmingham Jail that
Martin Luther King wrote it is so
important in in what wokeism actually
means and we watched it live in our
society in 2020 when the world found out
that that a white police officer has no
regard for a black man's life and is
willing to murder him on the streets in
front of people with cameras because he
thinks he has the power to do that right
over people of color and we watched
Derek shovin choke out George Floyd with
his knee and murder him right in front
of cameras and he'd had no remorse in
the moment or even afterwards for that
matter
and and the the movement in the streets
if that's woke I'm woke as [__] and I'm
willing to fight with any other mother
wokers out there because
the the the way that they talk with you
know we're gonna you know it's where
woke goes to die and all this [__]
again we said it uh I think I said it
yesterday the day before I mean it's all
just a dog whistle right like this CRT
woke all this [__]
it's their fear of acknowledging that oh
[__] this country was founded on some
pretty disgusting moments in history the
things that we did the people that we
that we put into into enslavement the
people that we we murdered genocide
stole things from pillaged like all of
these things and they don't want to
admit that because if they admit that
and they know that it's wrong
and the reason you know that they know
that it's wrong is because they feel so
uncomfortable with the truth that they
have to hide it if you had no problem
with it and you said yeah okay this is
bad okay cool
they would allow us to learn and have
the knowledge so that we could not do
the same things in the future right you
learn from your past mistakes so that
you can correct and avoid those things
in the future if not that's literally uh
Insanity you know doing the same thing
over again and expecting a different
result and that is what Republicans and
Ronda santis and all these other people
within that party attempt to do they
believe that if they don't think about
it and it's just like put the blinders
on like a racehorse that they won't have
to acknowledge it they won't have to
admit that oh [__] A bunch of white
people in our past whether I was related
to them or not did some really bad
things and the reason why our
institutions are racist is because of
them
white people you can acknowledge you can
acknowledge that that your grandpappy
was an [__] that your dad is a racist
piece of [__] and part of institutional
racism and it doesn't affect it doesn't
affect your rights and your equality to
smash Up Your Privilege with your
privilege so do it so do it and you know
there's a unique story here and I don't
mean to Pivot too hard into the alpha
cuck of the week but this is a pattern
here it seems because our Alpha cook
this story did not get a lot of
attention because all the [__] going on
it's still kind of well I mean like it's
only been a couple days right right so
it's still kind of Brewing but I don't
know you might not even know this story
because we haven't talked about it this
week even so that's why I wanted to
bring this person I was I gave the
suggestion of the alpha cook which is
Stephen Crowder now he's famous for
something what is he famous for he's
famous for going to college campuses and
sitting down at a table that has a stand
like a stance of something right and
then he says prove me wrong and he's
been memed for this a lot yeah and it's
a whole thing and for people who don't
know it's a common debate tactic that
you see from Ben Shapiro you see from
Tucker Carlson and Stephen Crowder
obviously you mean you mean Nazis is
that what you mean yeah I mean okay okay
and what they and what their tactic is
for people who have debated in the past
or maybe taken debate or you know were
part of debate club or something in high
school or college you know I was in
speech in debate in high school right
and I did I did a few debates but I did
more of the speech part I did the
humorous stuff I I was the clown can you
imagine can you imagine I'm just saying
no I can't I can't imagine
but for people who don't know there's
you know people have certain roles Tony
was the clown in his debate his bait
team but like what when you you happy it
was yeah it was not not definitely not
but you have you you're here's a topic
and you have to say you're Pro or con
right you're for it or you're against it
and you have your prepared statements
and sometimes you even have to debate uh
the side that you personally don't
believe in but you have to you have to
prepare it because you need to know to
say like okay yes that is true however
here's my Counterpoint now the
difference between Crowder and Ben
Shapiro and and Tucker Carlson and all
these other dumb idiots is that what
they do is they'll bring up the topic
and they'll create some straw man
argument or they'll create some fallacy
or confirmation bias and when then you
say okay well based on these statistics
or based on this study or based on This
research or based on this data right
because again benchpro says facts don't
care about your feelings
when you bring those things up what they
do oh and Matt Walsh is another [__]
one of these guys oh yeah that [__]
[__] but what they do is when you say
okay here boom here are the points A B C
D E F G right you if I can go A to Z on
them like Hakeem Jeffries okay you just
[__] school them on this and you say
you're wrong I'm right because of these
reasons then Stephen Crowder his [__]
go-to move and she goes okay fine and
then we'll attack you on a personal
level which we see all the time online
from Republicans who say oh that's fake
news and now I'm gonna attack you based
on your profile photo your name or your
sexual orientation your gender the fact
that you put a pronoun she's not my type
she's not exactly yeah yeah to bring it
back to a story this week she's not my
type yeah a 30 year old argument and
even older than beyond that too but
that's what they do Steven Crowder is
another one so he goes to campus he says
here's my stance prove me wrong somebody
proves him wrong there's literal videos
on YouTube where you watch college
students college students who are 20 21
22 prove him wrong and as soon as the
the debate pivots to say oh this kid
actually knows what they're talking
about and I'm wrong as Stephen Crowder
then he goes well you're just some young
person and you don't know about this
[__] [__] or whatever it might be
and that's the other trick personal
attack that's the other trick they do is
they cut what they want out of it right
exactly you know they kind of like I
totally destroyed this kid and they
didn't show the part where they got
destroyed also you're an adult coming to
a college campus telling people to
debate you on something and when you get
triggered that you were proven wrong
then you manipulate by cutting and
splicing the footage to be like I
totally [__] own this kid who's at
school
this is the real story because we've had
we've had um uh Texas ball in here and
he's talked about turning points USA
which is a different organization than
daily wire but but daily wire does the
same thing
um where uh
they're going to college campuses and
really trying to
um
indoctrinate this idea of conservatism
and alt-right
um views into the college campus now the
story is here which is the
um it's kind of crazy
I can't I can't even believe there's
this much money involved with this guy I
mean it's pretty it's pretty insane that
uh first off if everyone if anyone
offered me 50 million dollars to for a
four-year contract I'd be like yeah [__]
what do I got to do would you go to
right wing would you go right wing for
four years for 50 million yeah you're
like you're like you just tell the
orange like look for four years I'm
gonna be an [__] yeah but it's
because they're paying me 50 bills so
and then I'll be like look I'm gonna use
some of this money obviously to pay off
loans and things like that maybe buy
myself a house with a backyard because
that would be great oh yeah you're like
yeah you know just make sure that I'm
set up but then I'd spend the rest and
be like great I'm starting my own
[__] organization so that I can fight
this right-wing [__] because you
would be a right winger for four years
to get that money and then go against
the right one oh 100 I don't need that
money because I could make money on just
putting that money in the stock market
and making interest
so I don't know why I wouldn't just take
the 50 million for four years just to
know guys I'm gonna be a [__] [__]
and you're probably gonna hate me and
I'm gonna go to bed every night just
being like how to hate myself but I'm
gonna be richer but knowing that
capitalism capitalism let's admit look
I'm obviously capitalism is the problem
but in order to fight it I gotta [__]
go in I do right right right you got to
get them I'll be honest again I'll take
the money to [__] fight the problem
but you got to give me just to get out
of it well I'll reassure the audience
we're not going right wing anytime soon
we we do not have a 50 million dollar
deal on the table if anyone out there
has a 50 million dollar deal we will
talk to you but we do not have one
currently on the table uh the serfs has
it here on their Twitter account says
holy [__] Steven crowded was offered 50
million from daily wire
and not only turned it down but he was
so offended by the offer that he's
putting them on blast I ever wonder why
there's so many right-wing grifters
because it [__] pays I can't okay so
so Gabe
me and you privately talked about daily
wire this this last week
um and Matt Walsh is one of the daily
wire personalities and we all know Ben
Shapiro is the head of daily wire
um and he's got the number one political
podcast in this country Ben Shapiro and
I think Matt Walsh is in the top ten
folks that's what's wrong like literally
and that's why I'm asking you I know it
feels like weird where I'm like hey go
tell your [__] family and friends to
come listen to the show the reason why
is because they're winning because
people are listening to them and they
make a shitload of money and because
they got a shitload of ears this is this
is math this is a numbers thing I know
people want to say well more people that
they grift harder I mean they do Griff
but they don't grift harder inside their
media than any other media Outlet right
they literally just have
Millions tens of millions of people that
listen to them every day but the funny
part is they released a movie
they released a movie what's her name
she was on um
yeah that that [__] she was on the
Mandalorian and a lot of people liked
her in the Mandalorian and people liked
her so much that she was actually in
negotiation they liked her character
let's yeah yeah they like their
character right I mean
Instagram page there's no way you could
like this schlub unless you have some
sort of deluded Cuban on her right but
she I mean she did it to herself uh but
what happened was
she was in first off she was in in
conversations to have a spin-off show
based on her character she was about to
have [__] Star Wars she was gonna get
money million dollars 50 million plus oh
yeah she was gonna cash in yeah the
merchandise all she had to do was shut
the [__] up but she couldn't but she
couldn't shut up but she couldn't she
was like oh you should say she went over
against trans people she was like let's
fast forward through all the bigotry and
all the Q and on all the anti-back stuff
we fast forward and of course the daily
wire puts her in a movie they because
that's fine when when she was quote
unquote canceled Ben Shapiro said hey
because you don't have any actual films
going on right now I will come to you
and let's make a movie together right
and everyone's like oh look she's
uncanceled Ben Shapiro coming in to be
the hero
and so what happened that rhymes Ben
Shapiro coming to beat hero I never will
say that again I will never say those
words again [__] it never gonna say it
again so what happened was they made
this deal and everyone's like what
happened what happened and then a
trailer dropped for this uh movie called
Terror on the Prairie right
it's got some other right-wing people in
there it also has Daniel Day Lewis's son
in there too which is like one of his
first acting roles it's kind of a weird
Hail Mary or something you know I guess
I mean look the production value and the
amount of money that they put into it
this isn't the first movie that the
daily wire is just watch any of it I
started watching I have I'm do I'm
working under what was that so I have to
oh okay okay well we don't we don't yeah
not paying for it we don't want spoilers
for this yeah how much money did they
make how much money did it make though
that's right so so domestically they
said it made eight hundred dollars wait
wait 800 000. 800 no no 800 that they're
paying Steven Crowder 50 million bucks
man hey there's no way zero period zero
zero joke
Walsh actually tweeted about this if I
can find it here I want to see if I can
find this so basically they were like oh
uh uh it was revealed that they made 800
right and then people like oh that
number isn't actually accurate they
actually did make more money they made
thirteen thousand dollars
which
uh
most of the money came out of Russia in
terms of people that were paying now it
is a subscriber whoa whoa whoa wait a
second you're telling me that the
financing for this movie came from
Russia no no not the financing oh but
the but the money they made in the box
office right so that right now I think
the actual numbers aren't it's 804
domestically which I guess they they I
got it I I gotta show the audience this
I I made a mistake here I'm trying to
search for Matt Walsh streaming so I can
find this tweet I accidentally
misspelled this is why I'm misspelling
sometimes gets you a good thing because
um you get tweets like this Matt Walsh
is a steamy pile of [__] and he's right
about the lot R movies
oh okay but but he's a steaming pile of
[__] so I accidentally searched and got
a tweet from 2019. yeah from 2019 all
the way that so he's been a piece of
[__] for a long time I just sorry I
didn't mean to yeah yeah
so when I uh I just got to pull up the
article so I know so anyway people
mocked her for making eight because the
movie by the way the movie came out I
think seven months ago six seven months
ago so it's been out for a minute and we
haven't heard anything if you go to the
house the name of the movie what the
hell's the name it's called Terror on
the Prairie
um let me just make sure that's the
right name God it's such a oh my God uh
oh sorry yeah yeah yeah
um
so what happened was
it made 800 804 dollars based on box
office tracking uh site the numbers
right and they track all the money
that's there so everyone's like well
hold on 804 domestic what's going on you
know okay so turns out there's 13 000
actually that was there
now it's going I mean look it's going
the movie did as well as you would
expect and pretty shitty did it [__] the
bed it [__] shut the [__] bed
and uh wait who could imagine that uh
what's her name Gina carart Gina Carano
Gina Carano okay who could imagine that
she was handed up a great character in
the Star Wars saga of Amanda Lauren she
did a great job as an actress but that
character uh really delivered her the
ability to show her acting skills but
she would go and walk over to a pile of
[__] like the daily wire for a shitty
Moody like there on the Prairie be
handed a [__] character no [__]
substance probably all political theater
in this movie to send a message about
how they hate gay people and they and
they're obsessed with genitalia and they
hate people I mean the first the first
scene because I started watching and I
was like okay I gotta get it oh you're
gonna spoil it you're gonna spoil up for
this to see this movie
because I know you guys are [__]
trying to hit the ball you had to go
watch this one I just can't wait to
stream it after this show
uh the first scene is uh Nick Searcy do
you know Nick Searcy is a right-wing guy
yeah yeah uh he's uh I probably know him
if I see this is probably one of them
he's another anti-vaxxer all this stuff
you know loves Trump anyway so he's in
the movie right oh we're great yeah I
mean some people say this is the best
role he's ever done and maybe that's
because he pays he plays a racist piece
of [__] I don't know is it because maybe
he's never done any other role either
it's the only I don't know it's possible
you know
the first scene that they do in this
movie they're like chasing a guy who's
CL who clearly did something wrong
they they start beating them up next
year she's given some [__] proverb or
some [__] verse from the Bible
and then he gets down and he [__]
scalps this dude
just scalps him alive which I was like
ah okay you know what so he's supposed
to be a Jesus guy and then I don't know
I mean like it's everyone using religion
as an excuse for the the treatment they
do towards others right that's right
that's [__] Christianity 101.
yeah 100 so anyway I saw that I was like
oh God okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
outside and work out because I I gotta
remove this because they show you
[__] the whole thing okay anyway but
the funny part about this is that people
started mocking Gina Carano okay so if
you were to go back into IMDb and look
through the comments like one of them
says
uh more woke nonsense half hour in bunch
of nonsense all the men give up their
revolvers all the men have Stormtrooper
aim woman strong like World in
Terminator Predator Bullseye weak men
show all the all the white ends uh white
male in cells go and attack this movie
because it's too woke for them and it's
a daily wire move well here this is this
is great because I didn't know that part
because here is the back and forth uh
between yeah an account that's that's a
detail that hasn't really been talked
about right it's more so breaking news
then here I am breaking news
this is the one uh this is hilarious
because people need to the other thing
that people need to know about if you
really go through this thread or you dig
through and how it originally started
the person who wrote their their
critique on Twitter
did not tag her
uh so they gotta search they got a uh
notification yeah so didn't didn't tag
her and just wrote and be like oh you
know she totally dropped the bag and not
only dropped the bag but she put the bag
over her head and [__] sealed it off
right
that means that Gina Carana had had to
actively go to Twitter into search and
type Gina Carano or tear on the Prairie
to look for that review to find it to
then respond to it which then blew this
whole thing up and that is how we got to
this moment right here so this is uh an
account saying uh a reminder that Gina
carano's latest movie made 804 at the
box office 804 dollars not thousands not
Millions 804 dollars and Matt Walsh as
we know he's a scumbag who's obsessed
with other people's genitalia especially
children's genitalia and weirdly this
guy can't stop thinking about sex uh
when it comes to Children he just can't
stop he wants to marry 16 he wants
people to marry 16 year olds is [__]
15 I think 15 15. okay well you know uh
that makes the younger the better he
says right he literally said that he
said the younger the better right
because he wants to make sure he traps
young women in marriages so they have to
stay married to the scumbag for their
entire lives
but Matt Walsh goes on to defend this
movie
this is hilarious Gabe Sanchez I sent
this to you as soon as I seen it I know
I I think I responded to it but I was
like I just this is great this is
fantastic Matt Walsh tweets this this
guy turns turned replies off because he
doesn't want anyone to point out that
the film Terror on the Prairie was was
released exclusively on daily wire it
had one showing in one theater the funny
part is Matt what you're doing here is
saying that the daily wire their
streaming service also [__] sucks it
also sucks and that it's the shuts a
shitty movie that it was only plain pla
played in one theater so like what what
why is this a burn
um yeah it's it's not you're not they
always self own themselves dude this is
not the take you think it is you're
admitting to the fact that you guys
you're saying the movie really sucks
here man it's just like I mean you gotta
you got how to give it to I mean like
and if you scroll down I'm sure that you
know Community notes corrects that it's
actually a thirteen thousand uh I mean
okay well this is released it was it did
not receive a theatrical release you
could find this helpful I I mean obvious
obviously
um Matt Walsh uh text his buddy Elon
Musk and cried he was like please please
put a tag on this because how could I go
a day without knowing that this
Anonymous account is Mike Dale he owned
me on this film and I look like an idiot
when you can just delete the Tweet yeah
you can clearly man again this is not
the take you think it is like every take
that you take and you have you stand by
it and understand
that you're a [__] idiot and if
anything oh here we go he continues oh
yeah I'm sure it gets better I I don't
know if I read this I mean maybe I
didn't I just forgot but let's read this
real quick before we go to the winner of
the bonus of the week which we're gonna
do because we're past time here
he says uh this is in reply people are
making fun
of Gina Carano because her film failed
to earn money in places where it wasn't
showing and was never intended to show
you might as well make fun of the
Yankees for never winning the Super Bowl
this is also a horrible take this is
also he knows sports ball dude right he
knows Sports balls and it's only for men
by the way yeah sports ball definitely
never [__] played he might have
played one I could see I could see Matt
Walsh as the as the as a kid yeah his
dad forces him into football he's like
this is a real man Sport and it's gonna
it's gonna grow hair on your chest right
and throws him in right
and I guarantee it's like that classic
movie where they're like oh the nerd or
the like this little scrawny kid shows
up to play football and then [__] is
like six feet under after one play right
and that I think is Matt Walsh where his
dad forced him to go play football and
then the first day like shut up don't be
a man smoking glasses in his helmet and
his mouth guards like and his helmets
off 10 feet that way and he's like uh
and he's losing stars look soon if you
don't play the sports ball you're not
gonna get them women to be in the
kitchen barefoot for you is you know
what I mean uh the Bible isn't going to
do it for you gotta be a man you gotta
go buy lumber and put it in a in a
plastic sack at a Home Depot
um you know what's funny is we were
gonna drag um Ben Shapiro and Stephen
Crowder in this bit but we're really
digging into mattress here and here's
the last comment that he put on this
thread because he just can't stop
self-owning himself here he says by the
way the one showing was the premiere
event where we didn't sell tickets
so I'm not sure how it managed to make
even 804 dollars
couldn't even sell tickets to the
premiere are you [__] [__] me you
couldn't even get people to give you
money for a ticket for the that's how
shitty the movie I'm sure the 804
dollars they ran the premiere and they
ran the concessions so I would probably
I wouldn't be surprised at the 804
dollars popcorn came from single pain up
sold popcorn and [__]
they didn't sell M M's they definitely
didn't have M M's there hail no you
can't have M M's [__] no those are not
those are I mean they probably didn't
have Coca-Cola they didn't have Pepsi
that pretty much just removes all those
products and I don't know what kind of
woke popcorns out there but they didn't
have that [__] [__] either and I
don't know if it if if butter has
estrogen in it it probably does and they
probably didn't put butter on their
popcorn
because it would make you less of a man
holy [__] so there is um I don't know
how we got there but there's your Alpha
the windshield
oh the daily wire the the the drama at
the daily wire but let's go to the drama
uh in the House of Representatives uh
for our winner of bonehead of the week
representative George Santos we all know
the stories the [__] liar is a
[__] fraud of course he is he's a
republican yeah but Gabe Sanchez we know
this week he was found out that and we
found out that he stole money from a
veteran and his dog that service dog and
the dog disable the veteran and a dying
dog that was they were looking they just
needed three thousand dollars right for
a life-saving surgery and what did he do
he goes yeah yeah I'll raise the money
for you I'll help you raise it raise it
he he actually got the three thousand
dollars and then [__] bounced and
then the other time the whole time the
veteran is waiting hoping EX expecting
to get this money and during the time I
think that what I read was the tumor
Mass had enlarged like four times the
size in in the after uh after they had
raised the money and then he was just
like left holding an empty bag
and then after that he was forced
because of George George Santos
literally killed this guy's dog let's
just call what that's trumpism uh or
American Christianity or American
Christian nationalism for you right
there the other thing that happened this
week which is uh kind of weird it's kind
of a weird story
um that weird but I guess it kind of
makes sense right well I mean George
Santos was a drag performer in Brazil
um apparently I where his mother was not
at 911 right I actually don't have a
problem with this story but you would
think certain people would have a
problem with the story but they don't
seem to care
um that this problem exists in their
Universe uh one in particular would be
Matt Wallace because Matt Walsh goddamn
Matt Walsh hates him some drag performer
so much so that he'll uh Stoke his
supporters into calling Children's
Hospitals
um to um
put drag performers in danger well we
found out that that George Santos used
another name for charity use another
name to be a drag performer in Brazil
but is there any more updates that we
have this morning is there any more lies
that George Santos is tripping over this
morning we we don't have any more lies
but what we did see is that the official
so he's got his his Santos for congress
account right which is his campaign
account which is the one that he uses
this is the Twitter account right this
that's that's that's his Twitter account
uh that he that he had and I'll put it
up on the screen here that he used sorry
that he still uses for all of his
communication right on Twitter
okay but
the detail that came out today was
his actual representative official like
government account had been suspended
his yeah his representative account as
George Santos of New York's third so
this is his personal
account he used to run for Congress
that's the only one that he uses pretty
much to communicate through because he's
got Santos for congress on Instagram
Santos for congress on Twitter but now
he also has uh now keep in mind it says
campaign account for Congressman George
Santos but he also has another one that
is his George Santos
uh New York third account which
what was revealed today is that it's now
suspended which is weird because it's a
government accountant I don't know I
would have to go back through and look
at the uh the internet archives
like that
um
um that seems like a pretty big uh so
that's the thing that's confusing a lot
of people right now is because they
don't know why that happened right and
they're kind of confused especially
because it's a government account right
it's got a special great check mark it's
a government account I don't know what
he was saying on there that would have
been I I got a picture of it
controversial here's a screenshot of it
right so
I I'm not sure significant here that he
only has 180 right so I'm not sure what
happened when this happened but it was
revealed today that it was suspended but
then on top of that Nassau County who
already has beef with Santos and for
people who don't know Nassau Nassau
County county is the group of of uh
Republican leaders who vetted George
Santos
um
and backed him as the as the candidate
for New York thirds right but since then
we've revealed all these things all
these details about how he didn't go to
Baruch College how he lied about where
he went to high school how he wasn't the
star volleyball player player at Baruch
College that led them to a uh
Championship right
and all of these things were revealed
and Nassau County now has their own beef
with him they're like dude no we don't
support him he's got to resign all this
stuff George Santos will not resign he
says I'm not going to resign it will
take 142
000 people who voted for him in New
York's third to actually say I will
resign but even then I'm sure he
wouldn't resign and so the last part of
it is that I guess they removed him his
profile page from the Nassau County uh
Republican
uh politicians so he no longer has a
page they took it they deleted it from
their website and that is beginning to
show you I think more cracks are
happening in this in this iceberg that
is George Santos because we've only seen
what's above the water and we're now
we're beginning to get details of what's
below and if anyone knows how an iceberg
really is it's now is this like is this
like an amazing in like a in like a
cesspool because it really seems like
this wouldn't be an iceberg in a really
beautiful ocean it would be an iceberg
and like you know you know where there's
like parts of the ocean where they're
like oh this is where all the the trash
collects oh is that where is it like
Santa's iceberg is yeah they're like
based on where the whirlpools of the
ocean are it like just plots all of the
tracks collected all over the world
that's where it sits it's an iceberg
that just has a bunch of trash around it
but underneath is where we're like holy
[__] and I think now this this week
especially we're beginning to like crack
away at it and beginning to see what
actually is under the water of this
trash pile of an iceberg hmm well
there's one other development because we
got pictures this week of what looks
like George Santos uh being a drag
performer in Brazil which again I don't
know why he's ashamed of this
um yeah and here here is uh I mean I
know why he's ashamed of this right and
you know I don't know why a person would
want to be ashamed of this or people
would would make people feel like
they're supposed to be marginalized or
their predators or something because
they want to be a performer and put on a
costume I mean Trump puts on his Trump
drag every single day so yeah and they
love him so why why not love drag queen
performers but this is a video because
we got the picture but this is a video
game Sanchez of what appears to be
George Santos in his drag performer uh
calcium here we go
[Music]
so there it is
and there's another a couple other
videos of him um talking uh also and
we're not going to show him but there's
more videos of him talking about
um his drag performances like in an
interview on the street or something
like during a celebration or something
I'm not sure yeah there's several other
videos he just continues to deny denied
despite there being video and photo
evidence you know because you know we've
We've joked about it on the show before
which we say like George Santos is you
know he's a republican but he's the
worst Republican because he just like
takes Every Lie right right all he likes
all of the lies all the fraud and he
does all right and you gotta and
something to keep in mind here
is that New York's third right you've in
New York right Jewish population victims
of 9 11.
you gotta realize that George Santos
you know in many ways he's like oh that
sounds great that sounds great he's
taking these things in what I believe is
he's taking these bits of
um
of History right from New York City from
New York's third and saying ah people
really identify with that people really
like that so you know what you know
what's funny about that you know what's
funny that you say about that is that
there's been interviews here recently on
some local news stations some people
posted uh videos of this on Twitter and
we really were running out of time so I
don't want to find and play those videos
but a people who've actually voted for
him they were like yeah I really related
to him I thought he would do these
things and then I found out all the
things he was telling us about himself
that I really liked were [__] lies
like like but this is republicanism this
is is the Republican Party 101 Trump was
like yeah two Corinthians and I love the
Bible uh you know and and
right I mean he pretended to be
something that he wasn't the entire time
so you would vote for him and really
honestly to watch those videos of those
Santos supporters in their San those
voters the people that it should be
shown to in the story that should be the
Santo story and the reason why we're
going to keep I hope he stays in
Congress I hope he does not resign uh
even if he's indicted and the reason why
is because I want to keep telling the
story because if we can tell this story
to more people who have been duped by
other Republicans
that aren't that different than Santos
maybe they'll just [__] wake up and
smell the [__] that they've been
sold that they've been deluded on with Q
Anon and trumpism in general
um and just [__] wake the [__] up and
realize and hey These people aren't who
they say they are this [__] these
conspiracy theories aren't what they
what they say they are they're not
[__] real so that is why George
Santos out of all of our contestants won
this week bone end of the week because
he just he just gave Sanchez he just
isn't that real he's not that real I
still think he was made in a lab I gotta
I gotta tell you he
lied about his mom right I don't even
know if she's real I don't even know if
he has actual parents is he the only
human being ever on the face of the
Earth that's never had a mom he just I
think I don't know where she is I don't
know if she is you know they say
everyone has a mom and a dad right he
might be the only person who doesn't
have either a mom or a dad right I feel
like he was created in a lab but he was
like a [__] up prototype you know and
they're like what would be a different
name than a Manchurian getting how could
we mock The Manchurian Candidate because
gotta have the um a scam turian scam
Tyrion candidate
no no oh I should tweet this hold on I
don't want to reveal what the name is
okay go ahead tweet it tweet it scam
turian
candidate George Santos uh we're gonna
use I'm gonna start saying that scam
turian candidate uh George Santos uh he
is the Republican scam Turing so while
you're tweeting that Gabe Sanchez let's
give the scampurian candidate George
Santos or scantos I think is people in
the sky
it's about the people in the chat are
calling let's give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Santos
you are the winner this week
for bonehead of the week everybody
thanks for joining us for this segment
of bone of the week what a great what a
great history making segment here on the
Tony Michaels podcasting but are we it's
great to have Allison Gilford Mueller as
she wrote to give us an update on how
but we should have more guests on the
bonehead of the week I'm thinking like I
never thought of it before it was always
me and you yeah doing the thing but hey
it worked out great having a guest on
because
it worked out perfect worked out perfect
and you know that bone end of the week
is every single Friday here on the Tony
Michaels podcast and clipped to the
Midas touch Network so make sure to
follow at the Tony Michaels podcast just
go to the Tony Michaels podcast on
YouTube subscribe there we are live
every single weekday Monday through
Friday for two full hours but every
Friday in the second hour we break down
the bonehead of the week where you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week here's how you vote Gabe Sanchez
you go to YouTube you go to the
community tab after you have subscribed
and you vote for a bone in the week
every Thursday you can also vote on
Twitter just follow at Tony Michaels pod
that's at Tony Michaels pod on Twitter
don't forget to download every single
episode but Friday you can download the
episode with bone net of the week
in the second hour of the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget to subscribe again
I know I'm saying 100 times that's
that's me being good at YouTube
subscribe subscribe so go to the Tony
Michaels podcast on YouTube subscribe
also if you're on a Midas Touch Network
right now make sure to hit subscribe
down there as well
every single Friday bone of the week
what what name did you come up with for
with um so the scam cherry and I I have
I'm gonna but that's the scam sharing
candidate but then there's also
santurian candidate santurian candidate
yeah yeah
and turian
candidate well uh Gabe Sanchez tweeted
that out so go find that go follow him
on Twitter as well and I am Gabe Sanchez
you can follow me at the Tony Michaels
on Twitter don't forget to follow our
podcast account at the Donnie Michaels
pod to vote every single week for
bonehead the week because that's what
this segment is that's what you've been
watching thanks for joining us in this
edition of bone net of the week if
you're on the podcast the live podcast
stick around we might have a few
announcements
foreign
[Applause]
yes
uh bonehead of the week we made uh we we
did a first thing today where we had a
guest on bonehead the week so I
appreciate I'm going to tell Allison
Gill thank you again for for joining us
to give us the breakdown on the Alina
Trump have a story is that can we do
that Elena Trump
Alina have a trump I know Lena how would
you order that and maybe it's just Trump
habit
story do you think do you think for a
minute that Trump's gonna pay a nickel
that million bucks oh not a [__]
sense not at all he's gonna be he's
gonna play it off and be like I lost the
case or I had he tricked me she told me
he's gonna be like it's not my fault I
didn't do it
right she's a woman like that's what
he's gonna do oh that's beautiful that's
easy woman yeah he's gonna be like I
don't have to pay that [__] and he's
gonna do it and he's gonna blame her and
be like he's totally gonna blame her I
would imagine within the next 72 hours
we're gonna have a videotape of him on
some stupid [__] offhand podcast
where he he's not on camera he's just on
the phone he's on the [__] where he's
blaming the million dollars on her she
[__] up the lawsuit she did it wrong
he told her to do it one way she did it
enough who knows what he'll say to blame
probably that she's a woman
um more than likely but uh so we'll
watch that space as well speaking of
watching come watch this show show every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch do not forget
to subscribe here to the YouTube channel
the Tony Michaels podcast if you're on
another platform right now do us a favor
we are working to get to 20 000
subscribers two years of Tony come over
to the YouTube channel subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast not only that I
ask a big favor get three friends that
can come subscribe as well to the Tony
Michaels podcast share the link with
them and have them join the chat every
single weekday live noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific have a great and safe
weekend out there
until Monday same time same place Surf's
Up [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon